this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you so much for traveling up here
for the intros uh Carlin and thank you
all for coming I'm Amazed by how many
people are in this room
um a little bit overwhelmed especially
to see um uh many people with whom I've
worked over the years it's really
um touching to me that you've all come
for this little presentation so yeah
it's really hard to um
to summarize for the two plus years of
work and about 42 and a half minutes and
leave time for for a few questions
um so I've had to pick and choose how to
make some decisions along the way what
am I going to present whether I I'm not
going to present uh what might interest
the group what might tell a little bit
of a story
that's cohesive and um so my apologies
if I've left out some of the work that
some of you have been involved in and
I've Amplified some other parts of the
work that have taken place there's just
no way to fully summarize 42 years and
42 minutes so so let's let's go on and
and talk about my favorite crop that's a
good safe place to start grapes they're
fantastic they're amazing
um
vinegar grapes you might be uh used to
seeing Leaf types like this on on uh
Cabernet Sauvignon perhaps
um but it's such a diverse crop it's
incredibly diverse this by this
mustangensus on the right
um
would you recognize that as a great
belief shape tremendous diversity in
this genus would you recognize by this
hancocki eye from
um from Asia as a grape species
um probably not but this keys out to be
a legitimate 38 chromosome grape species
um
the diversity that you see is just
phenomenal what about by the stavidii
um also from China
um this grape has thorn-like structures
um leads are more recognizably like
grapes but this has been used in
breathing as well
they're not true Thorns but they're
thorn-like structures so not things that
you would normally look at and say wow
this is great for sure not everything
looks like a grape and the same
diversity that you see in leaf shape in
growth Habit
in fruit
size color shape texture
it just
well lies the the tremendous diversity
that you actually can't see the
diversity in the physiology the
diversity in the secondary metabolites
disease resistance that takes some
measurements to see
um you can't see it all but just what
you can obviously see with your eyes it
just belies the the tremendous diversity
with this species that we work with that
originated between the black and the
Caspian seas and through the
Mediterranean Basin and uh has well the
vinifera and viniferous Sylvester
species are from uh Europe and near Asia
um thoroughly plus species in in Asia 30
plus species in North America most of
them 38 chromosomes are tremendous
diversity
the goals in our program have focused a
lot on disease tolerance disease
resistance we'll come back to that wine
quality has always been a Cooperative
Venture with my colleagues in food
science
low temperature tolerance tolerance
early in the season tolerance in
mid-winter tolerance from Spring Frost
our objectives in the program of course
you can get some of this and get lousy
grapes so quality has to be an important
factor that you breed for Quality
productivity
as well have to be important so and you
want some ease of culture and management
these are important we have great
resources to work with this amazingly
diverse germplasm so germplasm
collections wow they're they're um I
always refer to them as my candy store
because I like candy sometimes and
um so germplasm collections knowledge of
genetics the molecular marker linkage
maps with Gene locations that we have
nowadays
the sequences of multiple genomes are
available to us and last but really not
least the fact that I am privileged to
work with some incredible amazing
colleagues in all fields of science I
think that's been
um an outstanding aspect of my career is
to have people all around me who who
just amaze me all the time
so so things started back in 1980 and
don't worry I'm not going to spend much
time in 1980 but there we are John
Watson who was a great breather and a
plum breather
um and the sort of one of the first
technicians to work with me Lucy Morton
the viticulturist who studied in France
uh Nelson Charlotte
Lucy mortens based in Virginia still
Nelson Charlotte unfortunately deceased
at this point but a world famous
pentaculturist and here I am 1980
picture is taken by Pierre galle a
famous ampleographer
famous viviculturist unfortunately he's
not in the picture because he took the
picture
so these were much simpler times we go
out with notebooks paper no cell phones
no tablets
um
we made crosses between grapes
um
we chose the best possible parents that
we could find and grapes are like this
they they are no two seedlings are
identical both parents are highly
heterozygous and the goal in great
breathing was to find the seedlings that
combine the best aspects of each parent
and leave behind the worst aspects of
each parent so over time I think we've
tried to become much more scientific and
deliberate about this process but I love
to share the amazing amazing Graphics
from my friend and former postdoc
Michael stream give him a little credit
for his creativity in creating Graphics
like this
so
um one aspect of my program that has
been a thread throughout my time here at
Geneva has been to to breed for disease
resistance so
um we look for sustainable long-term
resistance and uh we we know that
Growers spend a lot of time trying to
control diseases a lot of money trying
to control diseases and through the
1980s we saw loss of fungicides because
the pathogens would overcome those
fungicides and their effectiveness but
we also knew that grape species had lots
of resistance to to a disease we knew
the genetic resources were there so how
do we utilize them Downy and powdery
mildew or top of the scale in New York
other diseases are coming in these days
with a little bit of climate change but
we focus a lot of time on Downy and
powdery mildew resistance and the first
thing we did was look at germplasm at
the time there was no germplasm
repository in Geneva until about mid
1980s I think it's when the The
Collection was established so I went
looking at germplasm left to made by by
my predecessors
uh and they'd include lots of material
that came in from a program that closed
down in Illinois at the University of
Illinois breathing selections and
collections from herb Barrett
and among the germplasm uh accessions I
surveyed was was this one this
particular one Illinois
547-1 a hybrid of repastrous and and by
the scenario
and uh this turned out to be a good
choice for breathing work
um it was growing under neglect it was
growing
um in a Vineyard that received almost no
sprays at all for Disease Control
um and at the end of the season you go
up and find this this spine and a few
others nearby from other backgrounds and
they're clean they're disease free
they're also you never see trunks like
that in New York state but this one had
this tremendous trunk and was growing
beautifully under neglect so that one
and a few others were founder parents in
disease resistance breathing and we
still we didn't know much about genetics
of disease resistance but we could sure
select phenotypically in the field and
we went to a nursery selection procedure
where we would plant out our seedlings
from crosses with Illinois 547 Dash one
and it's descendants or other grapes
that we selected grow them under no
spray conditions cut the ones off that
had disease keep the best ones and plant
10 or 20 percent to the field for
further uh evaluation in the field
a little close-up of what you see in the
nursery you can see in the lower left
powdery mildew upper left downy mildew
and on the right side here's a Vine that
was defoliated in the foreground due to
downy mildew the adjacent Vine is
untouched and of course marked with a
flag that's the one we saved and the
defoliated types the ones that were
discarded so very much a phenotypic
approach
but still stymied by the fact that we
didn't have genes knowledge of genes
knowledge of molecular markers
um knowledge of chromosomes and where to
find traits of Interest so we embarked
on uh
a road to develop maps in in grapevines
and initially there was collaboration
with Norm Whedon Mary Hal Martins is
here in the back
um so Mary Howe was a part of this early
work on Ice design genetics and grapes
um and um well eight eight ice design
loci three of them uh there was three
pairs first linkages well I say likely
first linkages because it's as soon as
you say it's the first linkage someone
will say oh no there's another
publication somewhere that also report
the linkage so likely the first linkage
groups reported in grapes and then by
1995 worked with Muhammad Lodi a student
with of mine uh also teaming up with
Norm Whedon a first molecular
market-based linkage mapped
um with mostly rapid markers rapd
markers 16 rflp and isozyme markers as
well this was the beginning
um so likely the first molecular marker
map in grapes
uh there's Norm in the middle between
Susan and I he was here a couple of
weeks ago for a little visit so
um Norm left for Montana State
University a number of years ago but we
still stay in touch and glad that he was
able to stop by by um
the late 90s we have identified locusts
coming from that Illinois 547-1
uh Ren 2
sourced from by this scenario the locus
for powdery mildew resistance
and um uh so 1998 locusts identified
2001 we had a marker assisted selection
procedure yay one Locus one gene uh one
little bit of information
and we hungered for more
so a turning point in our program was
um the access we were given to run one
and RPV one run one for powdery mildew
resistance RPV one for Downey mildew
resistance these are genes that came
from the muscadine species for the for
the chromosome species from Southeastern
United States
it was back crossed by colleagues in
France like a lamb bouquet into a
vinifera background into a 38 chromosome
Bunch great background and later further
back crosses into wine great backgrounds
adapted to Hungary were made by Paul
cosma and Paul was kind enough to share
seed with me from which we selected
individuals that had the run one Locus
and rpv1 same Locus same same location
in the genome so this was really pivotal
to us because these are two of the best
chains that we work with for Downing and
powdery mildew resistance
and when you look at these plants that
descended then from the original
seedlings of egg air 9911 from Hungary
you can see in the upper left of an
unselected population
uh in fact it's a population without the
wrong one gene
devastated at the end of the season by
by disease and the other three panels
are all Vines carrying the run one Locus
for pottery and Downing mildew
resistance and you can see these binds
under no spray conditions are thriving
pretty nicely
so
um later in the process we we did adopt
marker assisted selection as there were
more and more genes to work with
um
a gene like run one we can pick this out
phenotypically but we had no idea which
genes had two three or four different
loci for resistance
and the idea was to try to stack the
genes to try to put off the possibility
that pathogen would mutate and overcome
a single Gene by having multiple genes
in the same lines
so through micro assisted selection we
would plant out Nursery Vines and now
they would look quite nice quite good so
the predictions being made by the
markers were quite accurate and these
these Vines were were really doing well
in the nursery
so this is all along the way of
breathing hybrid grapes in the program
but yet there are a lot of
uh vinifera grape Growers Growers of
chardonnay pinot noir Riesling
Etc Thompson seedless around the world
um and what could we do for those
growing venifera our idea was to use
um transgenics to uh to use the
biolistic process that had been
developed here at Geneva by my colleague
John Sanford Ted Klein and many other
Cooperators and
um
do some uh Gene transformation
experiments to check whether we can get
some genes board disease resistance into
vinifera grapes with the idea being to
try to reduce sprays hybrid grapes
typically take four to seven sprays per
season vinifera grapes 10 to 15 sprays
per season so so could we do something
for vinifera Growers without changing
the characteristics of the original
Vines
and uh you know Julie was with me
through many of these years Julie kicker
um Pat Wallace and Jose Vidal and a host
of others
um we had some of the we had I believe
this was a real first the first field
Trials of transgenic Chardonnay and
Merlot here in Geneva and also at a
location in California
uh in the upshot of all the work to
insert endocytenase from trichoderma or
antimicrobial peptides into vinifera
grapes was that we had some small
elevations in powdery mildew resistance
no resistance to guinyardia which was
blackrod under certain circumstances but
try this Bunch Rock resistance and
um
uh Crown Gall resistance some reduction
in Crown Gall resistance so we were able
to measure resistance to bacterial and
fungal pathogens
um
but none of this seemed to be at a level
that would justify commercialization and
deregulation
um the resistance levels weren't great
enough and the demand from the industry
was on and off on and off the funding
was both on and off there were many
people were hesitant to adopt
transgenics so
um so we eventually ended this project
in the mid 2000s
2008 or nine or so
um we no longer continued but we did
continue a lot of the work in molecular
mapping so
um molecular mapping Gene identification
uh techniques that we could use to apply
to hybrid grape breathing so what could
we do to really improve hybrid great
breathing and now I'd like to focus on
last 11 years or so since the vitus gen
1 and by this Gen 2 projects came our
way
I'd like to tell you a little bit about
the work that's been done a little more
recently and this has been a
collaborative project with Lance co-lead
on these projects uh Lance cable
Davidson and 25 investigators across the
country and each of these projects
Tim Martinson Anna Catherine Mansfield
we have a number of investigators who
have been on these projects in Geneva
Ithaca Davis California Minnesota
Missouri
across the country
so
um so let's talk a little bit about
these two scri projects they've been
taking place since 2011. the second one
ended in August this year the total
funding for the two projects was about
11 million dollars over that period of
time uh funded by the specialty crops
crop research initiative
um and I I'd have to say I had my doubts
going into the project whether you can
get teams of 25 people across the
country working in sync together
and we did that was one of the most
gratifying things is to see the progress
progress we could all make together
um given a good level of funding and uh
some again amazing colleagues who are
putting their minds to to the tasks at
hand so we sought to apply uh
technological innovations in phenotyping
and genotyping to deliver breathing
lines with powdery mildew resistance
especially durable resistance along with
high fruit quality and along the way we
investigated a number of other traits as
well
so
one of the
key Innovations in the by this Gen 2
project was a new marker technology
ramseat technology which was
commercialized with integrated DNA
Technologies
and
Lance and others had the idea of
developing
haplotype-based snip markers based on
sequencing a 2 inch 300 base pair
sequence
and such sequences throughout the genome
and finding sequences of four or five
single nucleotide polymorphisms as a
signature of a particular marker so
you're looking at a marker sequence as
an allele and as soon as one snip is
different it's a different allele
so the other thing about the markers
developed is that they're based on the
core genome
uh they're based on genes that are in
common among
um a diversity of great
um cultivars and species so North
American species binifera
um so the idea was to develop
markers that were well anchored
transferable and covered the entire
genome
so you can see visually the Improvement
in marker technology going
on the left from SSR based Maps or
microsatellite-based Maps
to genotyping by sequencing Maps done in
Vitus gen 1 dense markers not so easily
transferable from population to
population
and going on to maps that have 99
coverage of the genome an average
distance between markers of under a half
a centimorgan
so those are the the ones on the right
covering
incorporating both ramp seat as well as
GPS markers
another key component and by this Gen 2
uh Dave bedori Lance
colleagues at RPI Rensselaer Polytech
lighting Specialists
um
had some ideas about how to improve on
the vitus gen 1 approach which involved
a lot of microscopy to analyze powdery
mildew resistance and looking at
hypotransex under a microscope and this
takes hours lots of I-15 lots of time to
carry out this project and how can you
do this a little more rapidly and
phenotype even just as objectively but
much more rapidly and they they came up
with this brilliant solution a robotic
Imaging system
non-destructive you can image Leaf discs
that have been inoculated with powdery
mildew on successive dates one day after
inoculation three five seven you can and
you can analyze these the images you can
take pictures of elitists analyze the
images
uh automatically
um using a convolutional neural network
now they're Way Beyond that in
collaborations with Yu Zhang using
artificial intelligence to pick out
hyphen but this was a great Innovation
Blackbird uh the the more advanced
prototype is shown here in the lower
left
um
and just a little diversion from this
train of thought
before I go into some elements of marker
assistance selection so we did a
wonderful project to better understand
the flower sex Locus and grapes and we
determined that there are actually two
different hermaphrodite alleles
um
I can use the pointer up here so in this
project
we know that female flowers of grapes
are basically dioecious wild binds are
either male or female females are
basically homozygous for anaphylio males
or heterozygous MF
and in North American
um
East Asian and European accessions you
can analyze over a thousand snip markers
across the sex Locus and get basically
the same genotypes for your males and
females
so in this project they found two
different hermaphrodite loci and the
more important result for me as a
breather is the development of really
excellent markers for flower sex
so
um we could not use some of the markers
that had been developed previously in
the North American type germplasm we've
been using but these markers have been
working really well in the marker
assisted selection pipeline for us
so why this gen 1 and by this Gen 2
provided marker assisted selection
pipelines to Great breeding programs
across the United States including ours
and in the early days it was pretty
simple a couple of different genes of
Interest like run one run two are they
present are they absent which ones have
both genes okay save the ones with both
alleles discard the one the ones that
have neither allele or they have Ren 2
only or run one only discard if they're
negative very simple
um decision making but now decision
making is a little more complex but
now based on ramseek markers first of
all we can pick out the cells get rid of
self-pollinations that occur those are
the minus ones here
um we can pick out markers for a male
loci we don't want the males but Locus
254 Locus 18. they're they come from a
parent from the o-block
um
those are designated for the male Locus
and when they occur among the seedlings
those are discards
and the the opposite is true for rung
one when Locus 13 or 8 those are the
ones in blue or Lopez one for this for
the for this particular marker when
those occur in the seedlings those are
the ones we want is an F statistic
probability
um that's um that tells us which
seedlings are likely ones to carry run
one which are not likely to carry run
one so that's a sample of the
spreadsheet the spreadsheet goes for a
couple of Miles this way or that way if
you're looking at the screen
um
lots of markers lots of loci that we're
working at low side for powdery mildew
downy mildew resistance
so
um so let me go through a couple some of
the loci and other advances that were um
uh that were illuminated through the
vice gen projects
and this is really fun to do because you
know I'm only going through a portion of
what the vitus gen project accomplished
through a breather's lens through my own
eyes so in biotic stress resistance one
of our goals was to facilitate breathing
for for resistance especially powdery
mildew resistance across the country
so we developed lines that were studied
by Surya by Lance's group David's group
um
to um to look at this the to understand
the interactions between multiple loci
um but also we created
what we call Ren stack one and ren stack
two lines to develop single individual
clones that had all four loci so for
instance I made a cross with one my run
one
sorry that's run one and rent two run
one run one hybrids I made a cross of
that with Vitus Pie as ski pollen
supplied from Samara and Andy Walker's
lab
um rents and piazewski I carried Ren 6
and ren7 so we wound up with several
individuals that harbored all four loci
were tested by markers to carry all four
loci and the same thing happened with
the collaboration between preg Ledbetter
at Parlier California a table grape
raisin grape breather and Matt Clark at
the University of Minnesota
uh another cross that they made carried
six different loci for powdery mildew
resistance
four individuals from that cross four
individuals from Ren stack one are now
with Foundation plan Services uh going
through indexing protocols to be
available as pollen or as cuttings to
breathers across the country so they can
have immediate access to these loci
all in one place one pollen source
so now you know as we improved
phenotyping and genotyping with great
maps in Vitus gen one uh Steve loose
brought some information about
segregation of formopsis resistance to a
group meeting one day and Paula Barba
had good genetic maps for those
populations and by that afternoon
um she had located through g-was
she had located a gene on chromosome 15
from by the scenario and another on
chromosome 7 from cultivar horizon or
formopsis resistance two good
qualitative loci or femopsis resistance
so that's how we put phenotyping
together with molecular mapping
um this was a study now the next one's a
study I wasn't a part of myself this is
within the vitus Gen 2 project uh Lance
and others had been working and Dave
ramming had been working for years to
try to understand
segregation for powdery mildew
resistance
to send it from Tamiami by the zest of
Alice type source and eventually they
found
um rent the rent 11 Locus on chromosome
15 for resistance and very good
effective resistance on leaves rakus
berries and off and on stems as well
um in another study also this one I'm a
little bit part of a cross with Vitas
amurances grown at the McCarthy Farm
here
um
Lance Surya and team probably not
mentioning all the people that should
get credit but
there was a determination that there was
a rent 12 Locus on chromosome 13 from by
the samurences a new Locus both of these
genes have now been incorporated into
the Cornell Geneva breathing program
um and uh we're excited to be looking at
their progeny in the field and coming
into fruits in the future
um this one I
this was a study now another study and
by the samurence's hybrid population
sorry yeah going back to uh Ren 12 that
was actually across made in California
um grown in California but this was the
ambulance's population grown here in
Geneva
and uh work done by Lance Surya and
others located some new genes for Downey
mildew resistance and again I've also
tried to incorporate these loci
particularly the new ones on chromosome
13 and chromosome
um
from some 10 uh the ones that show up
multiple times in different experiments
to try to incorporate those into adapted
Pro material in the breeding program
so markers for fruit quality a little
more difficult
um to find markers for fruit quality
but through persistence and multiple
years of studies
collaboration with Gavin sex Anna
Catherine Mansfield
uh Noam reschef who is now back in
Israel as a great breather we did
determine in this one particular study
the genetic basis of anthocyanin
isolation in North American grapes and
there's a major Locus for isolation of
pigments and isolation is important in
color stability in wines so this marker
has now been implemented in breeding
programs
another study that covers a range of
characteristics but a focus here on one
particular
characteristic and that is the six six
carbon compounds hexanols hexanals
they're responsible for some of the
grassy green odors that you find in some
hybrid grapes
and in this project on chromosome 2
there was Locus associated with hexanals
there's still more work to do to to
utilize this Locus in um in breathing
programs but it's a first indication
that we might be able to pick out well
this would be great if we can pick out
some fruit quality traits years before
we ever see fruit
so we're making progress in those
directions in malate it was a multi-year
study again with Gavin Anna Catherine
avicarn Dave mans Lance noem rashef LED
this project for several years and we
studied malate levels in populations
here at Geneva and some other
populations in the by this gen project
and we located loci controlling acidity
or malate levels on chromosomes 1 7 and
17 however
these were not so transferable to
unrelated populations
and in fact if you look through the
literature you'll find malate levels
um
are associated with genetic loci on all
19 linkage groups so this seems to be
more of a a very quantitative
characteristic with different forms of
control in different genetic backgrounds
we've looked at um the order of Bud
break phenology of grapes genetic
studies of growth stages genetic studies
of Bloom timing
we've carried out in the last couple of
years cooperatively with Katie Gold
studies using hyperspectral analyzes of
leaf and fruit traits
and there's too much here to go into
much detail other than to tell you that
we're we are interested in some of these
climate adaptation related traits and
the Order of Bud break that may help us
avoid problems with spring Frost
so
um so I want to mention that those
studies were very recent and not yet
summarized but also
I want to spend the last few minutes on
the products of our program and make a
very important point with you
that all of the work we do
is only important if we can justify it
in the field if we can ground truth it
grow grapes in the field
and see the results and see whether what
we predict based on lab results and
marker results
is really true in the field after all if
we are to name and release a new grape
who will grow it if we have no field
data someone will be making a 30-year
investment
but they'll have to take our word for it
they would rather take data they would
rather know that these do what we say
they're going to do based on field
testing for multiple years multiple
locations
and through the project we have a lot of
really interesting seedlings
we're starting to make wine from some of
them some of them look very promising
for for wine quality as well
um and uh he's um to me this is the part
that's going to be hardest for me to
leave behind when when and if I retire
um
because I think that these by this gen
related seedlings growing here under no
spray conditions hold lots of promise
for the future
um if we were to review the timeline of
grape releases from the program
with releases in 1981 82
um melody was of some Commercial Success
Einstein seedless went to a number of
Home gardeners chardonnell was quite
successful in Missouri Michigan Arkansas
and really was released at the request
of breathers not breathers but
viticulturists in Arkansas and Michigan
more recent releases
2013. aramella is taking off a little
faster than Arendelle Arendelle being
the first grape that came out our no
spray uh breathing program our disease
resistance breeding program New York 81
next year other thing coming soon and
treminet a 1996 release very impactful
hundreds of thousands of vines have been
sold excellent wines award-winning wines
have been made
uh it's a hybrid with converge demeanor
and we see lots of wineries in New York
state making really excellent wines with
tremornets
by the way has late Bud break helps
avoid some spring Frost issues
now a little comment about one of our
more recent releases my inspiration
comes from some of the work on
developing tetraploid grapes 76
chromosome grapes not just 38
chromosomes 76 chromosomes is associated
with having increased cell size
increased Leaf size but also increased
fruit size
so Japanese grapes are amazing they're
large they're flavorful
and years ago we made some crosses with
some Japanese grapes crossed with some
of the tetraploids that I had inherited
in the breeding program at Geneva and we
developed our own tetraploid a naturally
seedless grape Concord light with five
to seven gram berries about twice the
size or twice the weight of a Concord
Berry
so nice little impact on breathing at
the tetraploid level for visually
appealing large buried seedless grapes
sometimes uh the numbers surprise us
from the more recent releases you can
look at the annual wine value and it's
nice to know the impact that we're
having these are back to the envelope
type of calculations but Melvin muscats
having pretty good impact Noire having a
pretty significant impact
um
over close to 19 million dollars worth
of wine sold annually based on numbers
of buy and sold based on acreage planted
aramella Arendelle released in 2013 so
you wouldn't expect that to be fully
reflected in numbers that go from 2010
to 19. but we're seeing a 50 percent
increase
uh between this period and
2020-22 so I think aramella is off to a
really good start
and you know I think we we've done well
in giving the industry some good grapes
to work with and I think I'm hoping I've
done well to leave a program in good
shape for the great breather grape
geneticist of the future
there is a search that's ongoing in in
or the culture
or a new Grapevine breather geneticist
genomics person and I think this person
has a lot of opportunities they will
have multiple selections but stacks of
genes resistance genes introgressed into
a cultivated background adapted to New
York and Eastern United States they'll
have full ramp seat marker sets for
everything in the program
um that's about a 2 000 Marker set for
everything in the program Plus
phenotypic data for a number of
biparental mapping populations
they'll have access to
um an endowed
fellowship and Grapevine Improvement
royalty income account with some
tremendous amounts of money in it
um
they'll have immediately the opportunity
to be part of this team some of whom are
in the room some of whom are in Ithaca
others across the United States but
immediately they become part of this
fantastic Cornell USDA team of grape and
wine scientists
accommodations would be available in the
soon to be built we hope the national
Grapevine Improvement Center to open its
doors hopefully in about 2026
and by this gen 3 project was funded led
by Matt Clark and landscato Davidson
Matt Clark at the University of
Minnesota I hope they'll have an
opportunity to join by this gen 3.
way too many people to thank to
acknowledge
um had fantastic students technicians
postdocs research Associates amazing
colleagues too many too numerous to name
individually great scientists on the uh
by this gen projects and I'm going from
these days in the 1980s to these days
spending a little more time with um with
family sometime but a little less time
with with grapes
I have all of these people to thank as
well the people in the upper two panels
um great supporters and off to
Great starts in their lives as well and
um all of you and so let me just wrap up
there and thank you all yeah
anybody from Ithaca have questions
I've got a question Bruce Steve Reiner
is here hi Steve sorry I couldn't be
there in person and um again I I just
wanted to thank you for everything over
the years when I first came to Geneva
you were one of the the people in your
family we met with you and you you sold
us on coming there our families continue
to be close our wives have worked
together for years our sons work
together continue to do that so again
it's just been really good and you and I
served as literally coaches together so
you really get to know somebody when you
do that
I wanted to put on my chairs hat my
whole my former chairs had for a second
and just thank you for being such a good
Department citizen it was obvious when I
took over as chair you did not want to
be chair but you offered your help in
any way you could and you were good on
your word whether it was committee work
whatever I asked of you you always were
willing to do it and you did a great job
with it and I sometimes we don't always
appreciate how important it is to be a
good citizen in our departments but you
you are the best example I've got of
that and I just wanted to thank you for
all of that and good luck in your
retirement
wow
so Steve the check is in the mail thank
you
and uh you're too kind and I thought you
said you had a question
I do have a question I do have a
question
um so after 40 years
what what would you have done what one
thing would you have done differently do
you think
oh my god
um no too many mistakes along the way
and you got to admit to making mistakes
um
hmm
but when I think about things I regret
God I really don't want to go into those
same saying the wrong thing to the wrong
person like the check is in the mail
I I if I were to do
um things a little differently I think I
I would have followed my
instincts and my training and started
disease resistance breathing five years
earlier I think I waited a little too
long
because I I think the road it takes a
long time to breed new grapes and I
think I would have been further along if
I'd started five years earlier and the
rest of the things I'm thinking I'm not
going to say
of course great talk
um so that is we're all excited about
what's at home accomplished I hope we'll
get it for you that is if one of the um
is the successful candidate
uh stand here today what one thing you
want to say
thank you
to them
um I
I would say
um don't let me tell you what to do
um
trust your training
take advantage of opportunities
please don't try to go It Alone
I by the way I hope I turned on the
ceiling mic so I hope they heard you in
ethica I I would say
um
collaborate collaborate is really
important
um I think most of us may be here in
this room but
maybe not everyone recognizes the
importance of
um being part of the team and
collaborating finding people with
complementary skills and
um
you know find some good colleagues to
work with
any questions from Ithaca
uh we have a couple more over here so
Bruce you uh you suggested that these uh
grapes are making very nice wines
but where are they
um
Alan Alan was invited to um Hawaiian
tastings back in September so
covet down there
okay
there are neglected opportunities for
making use of North American vitus
germoplasm
I think we've only begun to tap
position by the storm blind smoke I
think even if we've covered
screening a number of different species
there's such diversity within each
species I think maybe we've uncovered uh
certain alleles from each species but
shouldn't there be multiple alleles of
the same Locus perhaps within a species
so I I think
um
the identification of new low size only
only limited by the needs of breathers
the identification of funding
um to to screen for those traits and
then the identification of further loci
within species
there's a lot of untapped resources so
thank goodness for the germplasm
repositories that we have to to preserve
um the resources that are out there
chennaro sorry yeah so for table grades
and perhaps your wine beers you know
we're seeing these developments of candy
cane and uh which is uh wind drops and
all of these very interesting new
flavors that have uh come out have you
experienced any of that in your reading
program
and uh and participate you know for for
wine and for table drains yeah
well I have the room mics on but yeah
the question is about
um uh whether we've experienced some of
the um the inroads made into the table
grape Market with crates like cotton
candy or witch's fingers or candy drops
things like that
um
and also in the breathing program so yes
and yes first of all a lot of the
unusual flavors that are coming through
in the um
new grapes from International fruit
genetics in California uh they're
sourced from Vitus labresca they are
components of lebrusca grapes uh being
insert not inserted but through Crossing
bread into new cultivars with
vanipral-like qualities textures
characteristics good storage shipping
characteristics but flavor from Nebraska
cotton candy is a big example of that
um
when we also have people from industry
from California industry let's say taste
some of our Grapes of people from Europe
they sometimes Identify some new
characteristics that they find unique
and interesting and useful
um
chocolate maybe pops up is is one of
those words in some of the wine groups
some of the floral characteristics are
unique
um but yeah we do get that comment from
uh people from different programs that
taste our wines and they're also finding
certain unique uh traits and trait
combinations in our selections and
experience
foreign
has a question yeah
so Bruce uh I I became aware of the uh
something Beyond marker assisted
selection and that's genomic selection
and I don't quite understand what that
means and how it would be a different
approach is that the next
next uh Frontier to be across uh or what
what advantages or disadvantages
so yeah I think
um I think genomic selection so the
question is about marker assistant
selection whether the advantages
disadvantages is that the next runs here
I think that may be part of the story in
the future predicting breathing values
helping pick out parents based on more
than the phenotypes and the the
knowledge of what markers each parent
carries that's been important for me to
know phenotypes and markers what what
genes for resistance or isolation are
carried by different parents
um
genomic selection provides a lot of
opportunity that even some smaller
breathing programs are now taking
advantage of sweet potatoes I think
we'll hear about later today or tomorrow
blueberry breathing we heard about
recently
um the idea is to to use
um thousands of markers
predict be able to use those to predict
certain quantitative characteristics
and thereby uh utilize the information
to predict which seedlings should be
saved for some of the more quantitative
traits we've um
uh gone for the what we call the
low-hanging fruits in much of the last
20 years the single genes that have a
big impact on the program and
combinations of those single genes but I
do see that they're
should be a role in some of the uh in
going into the future with genomic
selection and genomic prediction but
um a grapevines are still large plants
we can't grow so many thousands and as
you get into
um projects that are looking at traits
that are controlled throughout the
genome I think you need to further
increase population sizes and find ways
to do that there are still cost
effective affordable
you know to really be able to implement
they're going to be some
uh practical hurdles to implement but
not out of the question
thanks
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu